might be hard to tell but that's Millie
Bobby Brown and she's singing shallow
you know from a star is born and I can't
help but think Lady Gaga would be so
proud
I love it and you know who else will
probably love this Mariah Carey's son
yeah me me just took to Twitter to tell
her fans how much her eight-year-old son
moroccan loves milli quote my son is
obsessed with Millie Bobby Brown
can someone please ask her to call him
and did you catch his pose in that photo
totally channeling 11 this is all kind
of funny cuz Nick Cannon not too long
ago also told us his kids were obsessed
with another young star Joe Josie wha
she's like a life-sized doll to them
when they see her they're like oh my god
he's Joe Josie why when they see her in
living coloreds it freaks him out it's
pretty funny but back to milli and her
Instagram video this is not the first
time she's channeled a movie scene over
the summer she and co-star Sadie sink
graced us with this gift from frozen she
couldn't just stay away you'll be safe
[Music]
actually we're not what do you mean
for now milli is on vacation but she
teased the next season of stranger
things to ET
for the fans who have just finished
binging it what message do you want to
give to them they're reaching for the
tissues what do you want I'm so sad I
really hope you like we're really sorry
that you're so sad but I got better I'm
happy that you're saying yeah we then we
did a good job Zach look are you ready
for season four please keep the door
open the curation changes keep the door
open three all right guys that's it for
today for all the latest on Millie and
Raya keep it locked to all pings 80
until next time I'm Katie crafts and bye
for now
[Music]